سفارات سيارات الاسعاف تهز ارجاء ما تبقى
مما كان في السابق منازل اهله بالسكان
صباح الثلاثاء استهدفت صواريخ روسيه
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف واضطر هؤلاء
السكان الى اخلاء
المكان لدي جده عجوز لذلك لا استطيع ان
اتركها خلفي واهرب اتبان في الممر وقع
انفجار واهتزت الجدران وتحطم زجاج شعرنا
بالرعب ثم طلب منا المغادره لذا تعين
علينا البقاء مع
الاصدقاء وفق السلطات الاوكرانيه فان
الهجوم شمل اكثر من 40 صاروخا بالستيا وتم
كذلك استهداف خاركيف ثاني اكبر مدينه في
شمال شرق اوكرانيا بوابل من الصواريخ
تسببت في اصابه عشرات المدنيين وتدمير
حوالي 30 مبنى سكنيا وفق المصدر
نفسه عندما بدا الهجوم الصاروخي اختبات
بالقرب من الغساله انظر اصبت بشرايا
الزجاج انا على قيد الحياه لكن الناس مات
ودمرت
شقتي تاتي هذه الهجمات بعد ايام من تنديد
موسكو بقصف اوكرانيا الاحد لمدينه دونيتسك
الخاضعه لسيطرتها وصفه الهجوم بعمل ارهابي
هجومي اوقع 27
قتيلا نحن نواصل عملياتنا العسكريه الخاصه
وجيشنا لا يضرب المنشات المدنيه والمناطق
السكنيه ولا يضرب المدنيين على عكس النظام
كيف وهذا ما يميز جيشنا جذريا عن جيش نظام
كيف نفى الجيش الاوكراني اي تورت له في
الضربات في دونيسك فيما تدعو كيف حلفائها
الغربيين الى توفير انظمه دفاع جوي اكثر
تطورا لمجابهه الهجمات الجويه ضد المدنيين